aquí tenemos la reacción general para
una eliminación de dos del lado
izquierdo
tenemos una luro de alquilo y este es un
halógeno general el halógeno está ligado
a nuestro carbono alfa y unido a este se
encuentra el carbono beta vamos a
necesitar un protón beta en este
mecanismo
entonces el alumno de alquilo
reaccionará con una base fuerte el sodio
con una carga positiva y un alcohol sido
con una carga negativa la base fuerte y
el alumno del kilo reaccionarán para
formar un alc en el doble enlace se
formará entre nuestro carbono alfa y
beta justo aquí veamos el mecanismo para
una eliminación de dos voy a redibujar
el alumno de alquilo estos cuatro átomos
son muy importantes en el mecanismo
todos estos átomos están en el mismo
plano eso representa la línea recta
y luego en este carbono hay algo hacia
nosotros y hacia el otro lado lo mismo
para este carbono algo que está hacia
nosotros y algo que está lejos
para el mecanismo dibujaré una base
general por aquí con un par de
electrones libres y una carga formal
negativa este par de electrones actuará
como una base de brondsted laurie
aceptará protones así que este par de
electrones tomará este protón solo el
protón dejando el par de electrones del
enlace estos electrones se moverán hacia
acá para formar un doble enlace entre
nuestros carbonos la reacción no termina
aquí porque si así fuera este carbono de
la derecha quedaría con 5 enlaces y eso
no es posible la mejor forma de perder
un enlace es con estos electrones que se
pueden ir con el halógeno dibujemos los
productos del mecanismo el doble enlace
se formará entre nuestros carbonos así y
por acá está el halógeno que antes tenía
tres pares de electrones solitarios a su
alrededor pero como ganó otro par ahora
tiene una carga formal negativa
es estable como grupo saliente porque
tiene la configuración de un gas noble
así que este es un mecanismo concertado
es decir que todo esto ocurre al mismo
tiempo y por lo tanto el resto de la
reacción para una eliminación éstos
dependerá de la concentración de dos
cosas depende de la concentración de
nuestro alumno de al kilo y de la
concentración de la base es una reacción
y molecular por eso se le llama el 2 una
reacción de eliminación el 2 significa
que la velocidad depende de la
concentración de dos de los reactivos es
muy diferente al mecanismo en uno del
que hablamos en los vídeos anteriores
otra cosa importante en este mecanismo
es el hecho de que estos cuatro átomos
el hidrógeno estos dos carbonos si el
halógeno están en el mismo plano volveré
a dibujarlo para recalcar esto
tenemos este hidrógeno unido a un
carbono que a su vez está unido a otro
carbono unido a un halógeno todos estos
átomos están en el mismo plano tiene que
ser así en el mecanismo para que se
forme un doble enlace en nuestro
producto formamos un enlace pi justo
aquí los orbitales se tienen que
trasladar de alguna manera y por eso es
importante que todo esté en el mismo
plano entonces podemos decir que estos
cuatro átomos están coplanar es este es
un ejemplo de cuatro átomos que son
coplanar y lo escribiré esto es coplanar
y como tenemos al hidrógeno y el
halógeno en lados contrarios entonces se
le llama anti coplanar es una relación
anti coplanar y podemos ver la
diferencia de una conformación antich o
plana si dibujamos un ejemplo de la otra
versión si el hidrógeno y el halógeno
estuvieran del mismo lado aquí nuestros
cuatro átomos serían coplanar yo lo
escribiré como aquí el hidrógeno y el
halógeno están del mismo lado
esta es una conformación 5 plana y como
todos estos son enlaces simples pueden
rotar libremente podemos pensar que este
enlace de la derecha puede rotar para
darle la conformación anti coplanar que
es la que necesitamos para el mecanismo
de eliminación de 2 entonces la
conformación anti coplanar es necesaria
para que esta reacción ocurra puede
pasar que algunas veces no vean el
término anti coplanar algunas veces lo
voy a escribir
puede que se encuentren con el término
anti del plan ar
lo que significa que no necesariamente
todos se encuentran en el mismo plano ok
el término anti peri planar es el que
usan muchos libros
esta es una conformación muy importante
ahora veamos un mecanismo actual para
una reacción de eliminación de dos
empecemos con el cloruro de termo tilo
aquí tenemos al cloruro de termo tilo le
pondré esos pares de electrones libres
al cloro
y lo hacemos reaccionar con una base
fuerte que se ha hidróxido de sodio
el hidróxido de sodio nos darán iones en
solución dibujaré una unión primero hay
que fijarnos en el alumno de alquiló
para poder identificar nuestros carbonos
alfa y beta este es mi carbono alfa el
que está unido al cloro alfa y luego
cuáles son mis carbonos beta bueno este
puede ser mi carbono beta o también este
oeste no importa cual elija haré que un
protón salga de este carbono beta diré
que este es el protón involucrado en
nuestro mecanismo y cuando pensamos en
el mecanismo sabemos que esta base
tomará al protón los electrones del
enlace se moverán hacia acá para formar
el doble enlace y los electrones del
enlace con el cloro se irán junto con él
todo esto ocurre al mismo tiempo que nos
queda dibujemos los productos
bueno por acá teníamos 1 h menos dos
pares de electrones solitarios no
participaron en la reacción ácido base
pero un par de electrones tomó al protón
y se formó una molécula de agua la carga
negativa desaparece y nos queda h2o el
otro producto el producto orgánico es el
que tiene al doble enlace así hemos
formado a nuestro alcance' y finalmente
nos quedó el cloro por acá solía tener
tres pares de electrones solitarios pero
ahora tiene cuatro pares de electrones
eso le da una carga formal negativa este
es el mecanismo de eliminación de dos y
lo más importante es recordar el regla
anti peri planar de estos átomos